Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter One, Episode Two: colonies, the Enlightenment, the first free constitution, and the wars over Schleswig.
Last time, we left the Danish king with almost unlimited power.
Now watch what Denmark does with it.
In the 1600s and 1700s, Denmark, like many other Western European countries, became a colonial power, from about 1620.
That means Denmark acquired land outside Denmark and declared it part of the Danish kingdom.
How did this become possible?
Better ships, more knowledge about navigation, and successful Portuguese and Spanish voyages of discovery in the 1400s and 1500s made it possible for Europeans to cross the great oceans and sail to Asia, America and Africa, to trade and to gain power over the people there.
A race for colonies began between Western Europe's big countries, and Great Britain gradually became the dominant colonial power.
Denmark squeezed in where it could.
The Danish colonial and trading activity had its eyes especially on Asia.
Denmark set up trading colonies at Tranquebar, in Danish Trankebar, and Serampore, in present-day India.
From there, Danish ships could carry spices, saltpetre for making gunpowder, cotton goods and other valuable goods to Europe.
Denmark did not establish actual colonies in China.
But trade with China, from where tea, porcelain and silk were fetched, became the largest and most profitable for the Danish merchant fleet in the 1700s.
Now for the darker chapter.
Danish forts were also built on the Gold Coast, on the west coast of Africa, in present-day Ghana.
From there, in total more than one hundred thousand slaves were shipped to the Danish colonies in the West Indies, the Caribbean: Saint Thomas, Saint Croix and Saint John, on the other side of the Atlantic.
On the Danish West Indian Islands, the enslaved people, often under physical punishment, were forced to work on the sugar cane plantations, or in the European plantation owners' houses.
The sugar was transported to Copenhagen, where it was sold on, either in Denmark or abroad.
The slave trade was banned from 1803.
But until 1848, it was still allowed to keep slaves on the islands.
Remember both years: 1803 for the ban on the trade, and 1848 for the end of keeping slaves.
The Danish slave trade took place in the 1700s, until the ban of 1803.
And Danish colonial history had a northern chapter, too.
From 1721, Christian missionaries arrived in Greenland with the support of the Danish king.
The first was the Norwegian priest Hans Egede.
Besides the aim of making the Greenlandic population Christian, the aim was also to sell goods from Greenland, such as sealskin, blubber and whale meat.
So how did it end?
Denmark sold its colonies in India and Ghana to Great Britain in the middle of the 1800s.
The Danish West Indian Islands were sold to the USA in 1917, and today they go by the name the American Virgin Islands.
Greenland now has self-government, but is still in a so-called Realm Community, the rigsfællesskab, with Denmark, together with the Faroe Islands.
Now we move to the 1700s, to the Age of Enlightenment, and the road to democracy, roughly seventeen hundred to eighteen forty-nine.
The Enlightenment in eighteenth-century Europe was a time of great change.
It was built on the idea that, through enlightenment, tolerance and critical thinking, people could become freer and better human beings.
Reason was to lead to freedom for the individual.
Such thoughts also reached Denmark.
The growing middle class in the towns, the borgerskab, demanded a share in power and began to attack absolutism.
But first, the countryside.
In the first half of the 1700s, there was an economic crisis in Danish agriculture.
To secure stable labour on the estates, the king introduced the stavnsbånd in 1733.
It meant that all peasants, who made up most of the population, had to stay on the estate where they were born, until they were forty years old.
The landowners were thereby assured labour.
In return, the landowners had to provide some of their peasants as soldiers for the army.
Most peasants in Denmark at that time were tenant farmers, fæstebønder.
That means they lived on one of the landowner's smaller farms.
The tenant farmers had to both pay a fee to the landowner and do free work on the landowner's land, to increase production on the estates.
Towards the end of the 1700s, the ideas of the Enlightenment gradually began to break through in Denmark.
And here comes one of the most dramatic stories in the chapter.
King Christian the Seventh, who reigned from seventeen sixty-six to eighteen oh eight, suffered from schizophrenia and was therefore completely unfit to rule.
The German doctor Johann Friedrich Struensee, who lived from seventeen thirty-seven to seventy-two, won the king's trust and was employed as his personal physician.
In the years 1770 to 72 he gained great power, because the king let him govern in his place.
Struensee issued a great number of laws on the king's behalf.
Among other things, he introduced a high degree of freedom of the press, and abolished the use of torture to make suspects confess to a crime.
Finally, he limited the peasants' duty to work for the local lord.
In many ways Struensee was ahead of his time in his attempt to modernise Denmark based on Enlightenment thinking.
But he ended up being arrested and executed, because the old holders of power, ministers, officials, nobility and others in the royal family, did not like his reforms.
He had also had a love affair with Christian the Seventh's queen, Caroline Mathilde, who lived from seventeen fifty-one to seventy-five, and together they had a child.
Struensee's rule therefore lasted only a short time, and most of his reforms were reversed again.
Even so, many of his reforms, and the ideas of the Enlightenment, would regain importance for Danish society from the 1780s onwards.
A series of reforms of agriculture and of the conditions of the rural population were carried out.
These land reforms, landboreformerne, played a big role in the development of both Danish agriculture and Danish society.
They meant that during the 1800s, agriculture developed from a medieval system with tenant farmers into a more modern agriculture with farmers who owned their own land.
From 1788, the stavnsbånd was abolished.
It meant that tenant farmers could choose for themselves whether to stay on the estate they belonged to, or to move away.
An important result of the reforms was also that peasants got the opportunity to own land themselves.
In many cases, landowners sold the land to the peasants who had until then rented it.
In many cases, the village's common land was also distributed between the individual farms.
In that way each farmer got his fields gathered in one place, so that the land could be farmed more efficiently.
The Freedom Monument in Copenhagen marks the abolition of the stavnsbånd in 1788.
Previously, the peasants' farms had lain together in a village.
With the land reforms, many farms were moved out from the village to the farmer's own land.
This move out still shapes the Danish landscape today, with farms lying scattered in the countryside, as on Bornholm.
The land reforms created a large group of farmers with medium-sized farms, the gårdmandsklasse.
In Denmark there were relatively more farmers in this class than in many other European countries, where a few big landowners, the lords of the manor, owned most of the land.
Still, even though the land reforms created a large class of farmers, life in the countryside was hard for the majority.
There was not enough land, and the land was unequally distributed.
So only a minority of farmers had a farm they could live from.
And a huge growth in population through the 1800s meant that more and more people could not get their own land.
So the rural underclass grew, as the so-called husmænd, cottagers, became more numerous.
They typically lived in smaller houses and had only small pieces of land, or none, to farm or keep animals on.
They therefore most often worked as farm labourers on nearby farms or estates.
Many moved into the towns to look for work, and some emigrated to America.
Now to a golden age, and then a catastrophe.
In the last quarter of the 1700s, Danish shipping flourished, and Copenhagen developed into an international port.
This period is called the Florissante Period, where "florissant" means "flourishing".
Through most of the 1700s there was peace in Denmark, which remained neutral in the wars.
By contrast, the fleets of, among others, Great Britain, France and the Netherlands were used for war.
At the same time, these great powers blocked each other's ports and sea routes.
So they sent large quantities of their goods aboard neutral Danish ships, which could get through to most places.
The ships sailed valuable cargo to Copenhagen, where it was resold to other European countries.
This neutrality trade brought great income to the country at first.
But in the somewhat longer term, the same trade also became the way into the Napoleonic Wars, with catastrophic consequences.
In Denmark these wars are also called the England Wars, because Denmark became allied with France in a war against England, that is, Great Britain.
The wars began in 1792, as a result of the French Revolution in 1789.
In the early period of the wars, Denmark was neutral and earned well with its large merchant fleet by sailing goods to both Great Britain and France.
The merchant fleet was protected by Denmark's own war fleet, and Great Britain was unhappy about that, because it did not want Denmark to trade with France.
So in 1801 the British fleet attacked and defeated the Danish fleet.
The battle is called the Battle of the Roads, Slaget på Reden, because it took place in the waters just outside Copenhagen's harbour, in the area called Copenhagen Roads.
It took place on the second of April, 1801.
In 1807, the French emperor Napoleon the First wanted to wage economic war on Great Britain by blocking the trade routes to and from Great Britain with warships.
To prevent Napoleon from using the Danish ships in the blockade, the British chose to seize the whole Danish fleet, and bombarded Copenhagen in the process.
The event is called the Bombardment of Copenhagen.
After the defeat, Denmark was forced to choose sides, and chose France.
The Napoleonic Wars ended with Denmark's ally, France, losing to the other European great powers.
This meant that in a peace agreement in 1814, Denmark had to give Norway to Sweden.
Over four hundred years of Danish-Norwegian union, since 1380, was thereby brought to an end.
Which brings us to democracy.
In the 1800s, Denmark was influenced by the popular and democratic currents that, among other things, came out of the French Revolution of 1789.
In 1848 revolution broke out in many European capitals.
There was no revolution in Denmark, but the unrest around Europe affected the country.
In March 1848, the middle class in Copenhagen demanded that King Frederik the Seventh, who reigned from eighteen forty-eight to sixty-three, should introduce a free constitution.
Under pressure from the agitated public mood, the king chose to follow the demand.
He abolished the absolute form of government and declared himself a constitutional king.
That means he would govern in cooperation with the people, on the basis of the constitution, the Grundlov.
On the fifth of June, 1849, Frederik the Seventh signed Denmark's first free constitution, "Danmarks Riges Grundlov".
Remember that key date for the exam: the fifth of June, 1849.
With the constitution, Denmark got a parliament with two legislative assemblies, the Folketing and the Landsting, which together were called the Rigsdag.
After almost two hundred years, since sixteen sixty to sixty-one, under absolute kings, part of the Danish population now had direct influence on legislation.
Who could vote?
Men over thirty with their own household, that is, who either owned or rented their own home, could elect members of the Rigsdag.
To be elected to the Folketing, you had to be twenty-five years old, while members of the Landsting had to be forty and have a high income.
Neither women nor the poor had the right to vote, or could be elected to either of the two chambers.
All in all, the constitution meant that about fifteen percent of the population over thirty had the right to vote.
Nevertheless, the constitution was very democratic and liberal compared with most other states' constitutions at the time.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
In which century did the Danish slave trade between Africa and the Danish colonies in the Caribbean take place?
Option A: The 1100s.
Option B: The 1400s.
Option C: The 1700s.
[DA] I hvilket af følgende århundreder fandt dansk slavehandel mellem Afrika og de danske kolonier i Caribien sted?  A: 1100-tallet  |  B: 1400-tallet  |  C: 1700-tallet
The answer is C: The 1700s.
It appeared in the May 2023 and November 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: 1700-tallet
Question 2.
Which country was the Danish West Indies sold to in 1917?
Option A: France.
Option B: Great Britain.
Option C: The USA.
[DA] Hvilket land blev Dansk Vestindien solgt til i 1917?  A: Frankrig  |  B: Storbritannien  |  C: USA
The answer is C: The USA.
It appeared in the November 2022 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: USA
Question 3.
Which population group had its rights limited by the introduction of the stavnsbånd in 1733?
Option A: The middle class.
Option B: The peasants.
Option C: The nobility.
[DA] Hvilken befolkningsgruppe fik begrænset deres rettigheder med indførelsen af stavnsbåndet i 1733?  A: Borgerskabet  |  B: Bønderne  |  C: Adelen
The answer is B: The peasants.
It appeared in the June 2021 and November 2022 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Bønderne
Question 4.
What did the stavnsbånd of the 1700s involve?
Option A: That the king had the exclusive right to trade with foreign countries.
Option B: That peasants had a limited right to move.
Option C: That Christianity was the only permitted religion.
[DA] Hvad indebar stavnsbåndet i 1700-tallet?  A: At kongen havde eneret på at handle med udlandet  |  B: At bønderne havde begrænset ret til at flytte  |  C: At kristendommen var den eneste tilladte religion
The answer is B: That peasants had a limited right to move.
It appeared in the November 2025 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: At bønderne havde begrænset ret til at flytte
Question 5.
Which country was Denmark in union with until 1814?
Option A: Sweden.
Option B: Estonia.
Option C: Norway.
[DA] Hvilket land var Danmark i union med indtil 1814?  A: Sverige  |  B: Estland  |  C: Norge
The answer is C: Norway.
It appeared in the June 2021 and May 2023 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Norge
Question 6.
Which country defeated Denmark in the Battle of the Roads in 1801, during the Napoleonic Wars?
Option A: Great Britain.
Option B: The Netherlands.
Option C: Spain.
[DA] Hvilket land blev Danmark angrebet og besejret af i Slaget på Reden i 1801 under Napoleonskrigene?  A: Storbritannien  |  B: Nederlandene  |  C: Spanien
The answer is A: Great Britain.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Storbritannien
Question 7.
What happened in Denmark in 1807?
Option A: Denmark had to cede Schleswig.
Option B: The king signed Denmark's Constitution.
Option C: The British bombarded Copenhagen.
[DA] Hvilken begivenhed fandt sted i Danmark i 1807?  A: Danmark måtte afstå Slesvig  |  B: Kongen underskrev Danmarks Riges Grundlov  |  C: Briterne bombarderede København
The answer is C: The British bombarded Copenhagen.
It appeared in the November 2021 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Briterne bombarderede København
Question 8.
When did Denmark's Constitution come into force?
Option A: 1849.
Option B: 1864.
Option C: 1899.
[DA] Hvornår trådte Danmarks Riges Grundlov i kraft?  A: 1849  |  B: 1864  |  C: 1899
The answer is A: 1849.
It appeared in 4 different exams, most recently in June 2026.
[DA] ✔ A: 1849
Question 9.
What happened in 1849?
Option A: Denmark lost Skåne.
Option B: The stavnsbånd was abolished.
Option C: The constitution was introduced.
[DA] Hvad skete i 1849?  A: Danmark mistede Skåne  |  B: Stavnsbåndet blev ophævet  |  C: Grundloven blev indført
The answer is C: The constitution was introduced.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Grundloven blev indført
Question 10.
Did women get the vote for the Folketing with the constitution of 1849?
Option A: Yes.
Option B: No.
[DA] Fik kvinder valgret til Folketinget med grundloven i 1849?  A: Ja  |  B: Nej
The answer is B: No.
It appeared in the November 2023 and November 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: Nej
Question 11.
Which island group is in the Realm Community with Denmark?
Option A: The Faroe Islands.
Option B: The Orkney Islands.
Option C: The Shetland Islands.
[DA] Hvilken af følgende øgrupper er i rigsfællesskab med Danmark?  A: Færøerne  |  B: Orkneyøerne  |  C: Shetlandsøerne
The answer is A: The Faroe Islands.
It appeared in the June 2020 and June 2021 exams.
[DA] ✔ A: Færøerne
That's the end of Part One of Episode 2.
In Part Two, we continue with the wars over Schleswig.
See you there.